[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de salud
del directo américa de france 24 más
romeros a la conmigo en el estudio mar a
muy buen día muy buena mañana de martes
hoy es el día de la evaluación de sangre
una práctica indispensable para salvar
las vidas cuantas donaciones más le
pregunto se hacen en todo el mundo
buenos días raúl pues empecemos
recordando que nunca son suficientes
ahora vamos a dar las cifras una sola
donación de sangre puede servir hasta
para tres personas entonces aprovechamos
el día de hoy para hacer un llamado a
que todos nuestros telespectadores
vayamos a donar sangre hoy y todos los
días que hagan falta repasemos las
cifras que hay en el mundo se recogen
118 millones y medio de donaciones
anuales de sangre en el mundo sin
embargo el 40 por ciento de estas
suceden en países de ingresos altos
países que sólo tienen el 16 por ciento
de la población entonces vemos de esa
desproporción que nos habla de que en
los países de ingresos bajos hay mucho
menos acceso a esta sangre que se
necesita para transfusiones por ejemplo
pues en operaciones complejas en
situaciones de conflictos o de
accidentes otra cifra y 56 países en el
mundo donde las donaciones de sangre de
personas voluntarias sólo llegan 50 de
hecho un poco menos incluso el resto son
donaciones de familiares o allegados en
momentos de necesidad o incluso
donaciones pagadas una práctica que la
ms llama pues a erradicar porque esto no
es un comercio esto se hace para salvar
vidas y también pues genera dinámicas
como que las personas que necesiten
dinero donen sangre de una forma pues
por encima del recomendado que se hace
de tiempo y eso puede contravenir su
propia salud mari para las personas por
ejemplo quién es esa miedo o impresión
donar sangre como creo que es mi caso
como es el proceso y cómo se puede
recuperar el cuerpo no luego hacer esta
práctica de donar sangre yo te lo
explico así vas a ver que es totalmente
seguro a ver si no me anima saber si te
animas hoy primero si se siguen todas
las recomendaciones de como decíamos es
una previa que no entraña ningún tipo de
riesgos y tiene que estar en buen estado
de salud se recomienda por ejemplo pesar
más de 50 kilos para que la proporción
de sangre que se saca pues sea segura
para el cuerpo y también de hecho hay
varias recomendaciones previas que pues
les van a avisar pero se suele hacer un
test o incluso previo de presión
arterial de niveles de hemoglobina en la
sangre para saber si realmente es esa
persona dar sangre o no cuando se extrae
esta sangre se saca aproximadamente 450
mililitros que es pues más o menos medio
litro es menos de un 10% de la sangre
que realmente hay en el cuerpo y por eso
esa proporción todavía es segura qué
pasa después de donar no el cuerpo
recupera todo lo que ha perdido primero
los glóbulos rojos que son los que
tienen una función por ejemplo de
transportar el oxígeno en la sangre lo
que pasa es que tardan entre unas tres y
cinco semanas en volver a los niveles
que se tenían antes de donar sangre pero
por ejemplo lo que tarda más hay cosas
que tardan menos como por ejemplo el
plasma que está claro líquida de la
sangre pero lo que más tarda en
recuperarse son los niveles de hierro
que es un componente básico de esta
hemoglobina que estábamos mencionando
que es lo que sirve de hecho para
transportar el oxígeno en la sangre
falta de hierro lleva a falta de oxígeno
y se puede tardar entre 3 y 4 meses en
recuperar ese hierro que se tenía en la
sangre por eso pues se recomienda que se
espere entre 34 meses también
dependiendo de si eres hombre o mujer
porque los hombres suelen tener más
reservas de hierro en la sangre pero si
se siguen todas estas recomendaciones
pues no hay ningún problema bueno vamos
a ver si me animo después a tirar el
programa a donar sangre y le pregunto
por qué es tan importante que todo tipo
de personas hagan esta práctica donen
pues es importante porque no toda la
sangre sirve para todo el mundo hay
grupos sanguíneos y se tiene que tener
en cuenta todo esto para saber qué
sangre puede ser compatible con las
otras de estos tipos de sangre se
caracterizan por los antígenos que
tienen los antígenos recordemos que esto
es lo que genera una respuesta del
sistema inmune la sangre puede tener más
de 30 tipos de antígenos distintos pero
los más conocidos son por ejemplo esos
que se caracterizan como a b o 0 o
también se le dice no que eso significa
pues que tiene tu sangre tiene un tipo
de antígeno a un tipo de antígeno ve que
tiene los dos que es el grupo ave o que
no tiene ninguno que es el que aquí se
dice por ejemplo en españa se dice cero
no se puede nombrar de distintas maneras
que pasa que si pones una sangre que
tiene unos antígenos que tu propio
cuerpo no reconoce el sistema inmune
podría reaccionar y reaccionar pues
negativamente contra esa transfusión por
otro lado también está el rh que es ese
positivo negativo que dice la ausencia o
la presencia de antígenos esto genera
como vemos una complicada tabla de
compatibilidades que se tienen que tener
en cuenta pero por ejemplo con esta
información podemos explicar por qué las
personas con abe positivo pueden recibir
sangre de todo el mundo porque tienen a
tienen b tienen el rh entonces pues son
estos receptores que pueden recibir todo
el mundo y porque los negativos de los 0
negativos pueden darle a todo el mundo
porque no tienen ningún tipo de antígeno
bueno mari qué pasa con las denuncias de
discriminación de algunos colectivos
sobre estas donaciones de sangre no
también estigmatizados y pues sé que
mucha gente ha sido rechazada por
supuesto vamos a terminar con esto
porque como siempre aquí unimos a todos
los sociales con la salud dado que hay
muchas enfermedades que se transmiten a
través de la sangre se intenta filtrar
todos esos grupos de riesgo previamente
pero entre esas asunciones de prevenir
riesgo muchas veces pues se ha excluido
particularmente a un grupo que son los
hombres gays o los hombres bisexuales
que muchos países impiden que donen
sangre de entrada al considerarle un
grupo de riesgo y eso es una concepción
por ejemplo muy heredada de la época del
auge del vih cuando hubo
pues esas cadenas de transmisión que hoy
en día todavía sigue siendo un problema
pero está mucho más controlado por
ejemplo se pregunta tu orientación
sexual una práctica que es relativamente
violenta a veces no si vas a pelear a
donar sangre pues no esperas que te
pregunten eso y además es muy importante
recordar que hoy en día la sangre
siempre se revisa antes de usarse
entonces hay unas tecnologías que
recuerdan que la orientación sexual
realmente no es el filtro que se debería
usar sino quizás pues las prácticas que
se tienen no no hay nada que haga el
sexo homosexual la más riesgoso que el
sexo heterosexual entonces recordemos
como siempre son las prácticas las que
pueden ser seguras o inseguras no la
orientación entonces pues cada vez hay
más voces que lo leen que se eliminen
estas exclusiones y estas
discriminaciones y pues yo también creo
que la persona sensata y si cree que
puede tener algún tipo de enfermedad
pues no iría a donar sangre por supuesto
siempre hacer setters regulares también
para controlar el estado de salud marc
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información de salud nos vamos a
saludar a nuestro segundo invitado el
día